hello everyone and welcome to round five
of this year's Norway chess where all of
the games that were played were
incredibly interesting and a lot has
happened in the world regarding the live
ratings we're gonna discuss that I'm
pretty sure you already know what I'm
talking about but let's first check out
the game as this is one of the games
that's uh mostly responsible for the
occurrence so it's hikarnakamura versus
I think it was even tari's birthday so
we had two birthdays this uh
tournamentari uh so you know he uh not
doing all that great in the tournament
he would very much enjoy at least some
points against hikar okay maybe not win
classical but you know getting it to
Armageddon would be nice so let's check
out what happened here Hikaru has the
white pieces at this classical and he
opens with Pawn to E4 at Pawn to E5 and
Hikaru goes for Bishop to C4 uh sorry
about that uh the so-called Bishop's
opening we have Knight to F6 and now
Pawn to D3 sort of uh and uh you know an
older some sort of a parallel universe
London system setup Bishop to C5 and now
uh Knight the C3 we have Pawn to C6
preparing to strike in the center Bishop
to B3 and First Pawn to D6 with Pawn to
H3 and Aryan castles and Hikaru now goes
Knight to F3 there is a game in the
database from 2008 uh Alexander
morsevich played it against rifan at
around he played Queen to F3 and the
game ended in a draw but here Knight to
F3 and it is now already as of move 7
that we have a completely new game
Hikaru wants completely new territory as
early on as possible everyone else is
beating tari so Hikaru wants to beat him
as well and also that's one of the
problems when you're not doing that
great in a tournament maybe if you were
doing great you know uh people would be
like okay you didn't take points away
from others
we can have a draw but if everyone else
beats you and gets a full three points
then everyone else will want to beat you
as well so that's why uh anov beat
approached by hikar Arrow Pawn to A5 and
now castles we have Knight beat the D7
Ponte A3 and now Pawn to B5 30 grabs
more space on the queen side push up to
A2 and now uh even Knight the H4 uh
sorry uh nothing tonight the H5 uh A4
first uh and now Knights the H4 they are
going after this F5 Square uh Hikaru
testing if Aryan will play G6 which will
prevent Knight F5 but also weaken the
black king side uh so he doesn't he just
goes back Bishop to A7 now comes Queen
to F3 and Knight to C5 and Hikaru just
goes for Knight to F5 and it would be
too dangerous to keep this Knight on F5
you have to worry about too much it just
controls too many uh crucial squares
here uh you know some checkmating
threads might also be possible so Aryan
just traded the bishop captures on F5 a
queen captures on F5 and now Rook the E8
just nicely developing you have to be a
little bit worried about this light
Square version but as long as the night
is on F6 and there's no way to dislodge
it from there it should be perfectly
fine so Bishop the D2 by Hikaru Knights
the E6 and now Knight the E2 we have
Pawn to D5 striking in the center and E
captures on D5 and now a very
interesting moment
um uh in the game uh tari does not
capture towards the center with C
captures on D5 even though I have no
idea why it seems like a a perfectly
fine idea where you get all the central
squares and of course this is never an
option Queen captures the pawn is never
an option because now it goes back and
you lose the Knight I need to so I have
no idea why tari did not capture uh C
captures on D5 he played Knight captures
on the E5 and okay uh your position is
okay but uh I mean you you don't have
the full Center so at least for my level
of understanding chess that's a bit
weird Rook 881 and now Queen to D6
developing the queen connecting the
Rooks we have Queen to G4 now with some
ideas of going after the black king and
the Rook 8 to d8 we have Knights the G3
now the Knight can come to F5 to H5 and
put even more pressure on the black king
with knights the D4 putting pressure on
the C2 pawn and here while you could
kick it away with C3 then a knight B3
and then okay the light Square Bishop
will not be as powerful you will have to
give it up for this Knight at some point
Hikaru first place Bishop to G5 and now
Aryan moves The Rook uh the the critical
line here is Pawn to F6 as it often is I
mean yeah it's either good or it's not
uh but the problem is it kind of opens
up this diagonal and here you might run
into something like Knight to E4 attacks
the queen and once the queen moves
because you really want to keep an eye
on that F6 Pawn you will capture F
captures Bishop captures and F6 Queen
captures in G4 H captures G captures and
not even Knight captures on F6 because
the Knight cannot move uh and after King
F7 you will grab uh The Rook here
captures captures or captures and okay
you will have two knights for The Rook
it's a pretty uh you know uh it's
definitely a trade-off uh it's hard to
say who would have the advantage here
two knights of course are scary but the
white the black king is white in the
open once the position opens up uh those
two Rooks will be incredibly powerful
especially you know complemented by the
bishop on this um long diagonal so
instead Rook the B8 by 30 and now Bush
will be back to E3 by Hikaru also you
need to counter this bishop itself it's
a magnificent piece Queen to G6 offering
a queen trade and just Pawn to C3
kicking away the Knight Knight captures
an E3 first F captures an E3 and now
Knights the B3 and now Knights the E4 uh
it's a excellent Square for the Knight
you can bring it to D6 you can bring it
over to F5 uh Queen cap percent G4 H
capture Sun G4 and now you should play
something like Rook B to d8 and put
pressure on the backwards the D3 Pawn uh
but tari played Pawn to C5 and this uh
makes it very very hard for him to play
the game what he did with the C5 move is
that he basically uh locked his own dark
Square Bishop out of the game how are
you getting this like a dark sport
version part of the game you will have
to play something like uh maybe here
here here here but even if you get it to
E7 the Knight you're just controlling
all of these squares it's gonna be it's
gonna be a bad piece so Hikaru fully
takes advantage of this he plays Bishop
captures on B3 eight captures and now c4
just keeping the pawn on C5 that's how
he locks it in capturing does absolutely
nothing the bishop is still out of the
game sotara instead goes Rook to d8 goes
after the uh rookie to d8 for those of
you who are maybe just listening not
watching Rook to D1 and now Rook to D7
and now King to F2 uh Hikaru gets the
king into the game of course ready to
meet The Rook uh beat the d8 with King
T2 guarding the D3 Pawn so H5 30 wants
to gain control over df5 Square so if
Hikaru captures he can push F5 but
Hikaru says that's perfectly fine you
just push that F5 Pawn because my knight
is then coming to C3 and then to D5 and
you know what this means of course uh F5
Knights the C3 now hikaru's Knight is
coming to D5 or even the B5 if possible
but the thing is both of those are light
squares and you have a dark Square
Bishop you have the two Rooks so either
that Knight is staying on that light
Square for the rest of the game or you
will at some point have to give up the
exchange
at the trade so Pawn the B4 attacks the
knight at Knight the B5 now puts
pressure on the bishop on A7 uh and now
Pawn to F4 by 30 and this uh further
um uh advances hikaru's Advantage here
you should probably play B captures on
A3 and after Knight captures just uh you
know keep the bishop safe and keep the
position closed but it's still very very
hard to play this the Knight will again
be re-maneuvered over to C3 then to D5
and it will just be a monster there so
instead a taddy played Pawn to F4 now
Hikaru plays a capture some B4 Bishop to
B6 and now e captures on F4 we have C
capture some B4 and now King the F3 uh
we have e captures on F4 and now uh the
uh the only move in the position that
gives why the Advantage pawn to D4 of
course the Knight here guards the D4
Pawn also The Rook here and now you will
just start advancing those pawns uh Rook
B to d8 Atari doubles up on the D file
but now not D5 the move you you were
expecting because here you will never be
able to push further and also C5 will
never be an option so the idea will be
to push C5 not D5 and Hikaru plays Rook
to D3 just shows that this is never a
threat because if you capture then a
Hikaru will just double up on the D file
and you lose material here and of course
you throw captures then just Knight wins
material so Rook the C8 and it's a it's
it's soup's one there's no move here
that tari can make you can't really do
any moves with the King you can't do
anything with the bishop uh once uh if
the Rook moves away from the D file then
you're just gonna capture the B3 Pawn so
there's really nothing here he tried
Rook to C8 kinda going after the C4 Pawn
but um Hikaru was waiting for just that
Rook to C1 and now Rook to D5 if you if
you now repeat Rook C to D then C5 comes
and his game over Bishop day seven let's
say C6 attacks the Roku Rook moves
anywhere C7 cuts off The Rook from the
defense of the bishop next move you're
gonna capture the bishop so
um yeah or The Rook or promote or you
know the rig depends on what black plays
but here Rook the D5 was played this is
a sort of a last resort move for tari uh
saying that if capture I'm gonna capture
on C1 and even this is winning for
Hikaru but Hikaru doesn't play that he
carplays Pawn to C5 uh Rook to G5 now
going after Rook to G3 check but now
we've reached move 40 uh but tari's
position is completely lost feel free to
pause the video and try to find the
absolute best move for Hikaru while I
give you a couple of seconds I just
realized my laundry basket was in the
back when I checked the camera so sorry
about that uh but you know what you're
gonna do you have to you have to do your
laundry
um uh so yeah uh uh uh if you were able
to do it congratulations on spotting
this very nice idea and for those of you
who just want to enjoy the show it is
Knight to D6 that's the good stuff uh
just going after the Rook the bishop's
still hanging uh and there's uh no good
way to handle this even if you even if
you go for Rook to G3 uh check and let's
say a king T4 uh you could capture on D3
it's not a problem King captures you
still have all the same problems and
there's no uh there's no playing this
what do you want to play Bishop to A7
then just Knight captures and C8 uh if
you don't then you're gonna lose the
lose the bishop and you don't even care
about Rook captures and C1 because the
pawn will promote and it's sort of what
happened in the game after Rook to G5
Knight to D6 Rook the C6 was played
saying okay maybe Hikaru doesn't see it
but he is the the the the the master of
of the puzzle Rush uh so of course he
spots it in in an instant and he already
saw it like 10 moves ago so it's not a
problem see captures on B6 played and he
was in this position on move 42 that
ariantari resigned the game as there is
nothing more to be done here so
beautifully done by Hikaru of course if
the Rook is captured just spawn to C7
promotes to a queen there is no way of
stopping this uh there are no tricks
here like Rook to G3 checking T4 Rook to
E1 check can be played King to F5 King
to D5 you don't really care no more
checks in the position next move you
promote and that's it the Knight covers
d8 so E8 so that's out of the question
so yeah here he resigned uh once again
congratulations if you were able to find
this puzzle and yeah what does this mean
for uh for the tournament standings uh
for or for for the live ratings let's
check it out so now uh Fabi is still in
the lead because we said in the previous
round that he was so far ahead of
everyone that even if he lost the next
classical game and hikar won he would
still be leading the tournament so even
though uh Hikaru doing extremely well if
Fabiano continues playing well it will
be his tournament there we have so
Fabiano uh Hikaru alereza those are the
top three then with seven points
with six points Magnus Carlton on each
gear and Wesley so uh and uh and uh
which two points in last place uh Aryan
tari uh this these were the encounters
if you don't uh want me to spoil that
you know uh stop watching so here they
are uh so uh another bit lost
Fabiano lost the momentarov probably the
next game I'm going to show in classical
uh pretty uh tough uh loss for Fabiano
uh alireza defeated Wesley so in
Armageddon Hikaru defeated tari in this
beautiful classical game that we've just
seen and the Magnus was able to best
anijigiri also in Armageddon and what
does this mean for the uh live ratings
uh there you have it Hikaru Nakamura is
the new world number two he tops uh uh
ding Fabian dalireza and now is only
bested by Magnus Carlsen and look at the
the weird rating distribution now okay
Magnus Carlsen always ahead of everyone
you know by by a lot 28 41 but now look
at this he called 2783.5 while it is a
2783.2 he uh Fabiano
2782.4 a ding 2780 2779 for Nepal and
danish 2772 so uh imagine if Magnus
after this tournament says all right you
know I'm done with chess I'm just gonna
uh officially retire and then he is no
longer counted in the ratings much like
casparov if kasparov's rating was still
uh was still uh counting he would
actually be world number two I don't
know if you guys know that because uh
well he just retired with a very very
high rating uh but yeah if Magnus just
retired then we would have a different
world number one maybe even on a daily
basis so it would be complete chaos uh
so yeah we'll see what the future brings
um you know it's always interesting in
the Chess World so stay tuned for that
uh I would like to thank Mikhail Sakari
as David gasparia and Brandon fukuda
Nicholas wolf and Andres Fel news for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot I really appreciate it as usual you
can check two of my previous videos here
thank you for watching and I will see
you soon most likely with that Fabi
shark game as it is uh well it is just a
very nice game so thank you all I will
see you soon and have an excellent rest
of your day